I think in a lot of ways we we don't
know someone that's going on I mean we
we did read a fair amount of news why
should say myself and a lot of my
friends we would read a lot of news but
not really that much and then what we
experience while we're there is so it's
like really the whole forest for the
trees thing where we could tell you a
lot about our specific missions or
anything like on a tactical level but as
far as like kind of more overarching big
picture type stuff I would you back in
America watching the news probably have
a better grasp of what's going on big
picture ish then we live definitely
well yeah that's kind of the drag and I
guess really kind of the standard thing
with combat is in my area roughly
speaking every time in 10 there was any
kind of engagement there would mrs. by
my own non-scientific count there would
usually be about one combatant killed 43
non-combatants killed and by combat I
mean like good guy bad guy you know
insurgents coalition forces so shooting
starts maybe a couple of combatants go
down tons of women and children get
blasted in the process which i think is
my humble opinion like I think it's kind
of a statistic and that isn't looked at
often enough these combats great and
everything but if you're there I'll
sensibly the help of people but in the
process of helping them you're kind of
like killing all of them you know it's
maybe someone should look at that more
closely Paul rycoff the executive
director of iava had a kind of a really
good way of putting it is that you know
we're creating enemies more quickly than
we can kill them because you know you're
on isms home you kind of accidentally
kill a lot of people that's never a good
thing you know you're making enemies a
lot faster than you'd like